Let me fix the chat.
I hope the cutscene plays again because I was watching
something.
Oh, oh, there it goes.
Okay, it does play.
Let's watch this.
I was watching without sound.
Also, this is a marvelous game.
I had no idea.
Welcome to Tenly Premonition.
We'll watch this.
It seems kind of long, though.
Yep.
The children.
You're a marvelous game.
It's a game.
It is... This game is as marvelous as it gets.
I meant, you know, marvelous behind Sinran Kagura.
Psychotic cats.
It's dangerous to run around here, boys.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Grandpa, hurry.
Grandpa, you're too slow.
Marvelous ladybug.
I'm grandpa.
Watch out for pixelated bazongas.
I did see those.
Oh, and so did they.
Oh, no.
Children, avert your eyes!
What is this song?
A lot of hoopla for this ghost idol, huh, Zach?
Hope you love this wacky, stupid pseudo-fifty- Who all is
involved in this game?
Oh.
Eww!
Oh my god!
It's Oh my god!
It's a good thing she's censored.
Oh!
This is...
This is alternate Inuyasha, I think, maybe.
Oh my god!
children need to look away please can somebody think of the
children for a one can we actually think of the children
grandpa look up
oh finally and oh you know her hello me doing i was like you
actually never heard of this game i've only heard absurd
things that's all i've heard too looking forward to
experiencing it with you Yeah!
Me too!
Oh.
That snake?
Me.
The boss?
I totally thought it too.
The danger noodle.
Deadly premonition.
I do truly know, like, I actually like nothing about this
game.
So I'm very excited.
Um...
for to learn anything and everything.
LA Promenade is my favorite game of all time.
Good luck with the investigation.
FBI Special Agent Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you Burger Queen.
Thanks for the super chat.
You are in for a treat.
Oh, the children.
Oh, they don't care at all.
Actually, they don't care.
They don't care.
They're not traumatized at all.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, sorry.
They're giving Rem and Ram.
Why are the kids still there?
What?
Did she know Anna?
What is she holding up?
Oh, why are you holding her up so high?
Everybody has to hold every object The highest in the air Is
she laughing or crying?
Yes, girl, give us nothing
So far everybody's hot, though It's great The music is
awesome
Is she crying too?
Oh my god.
Most beloved woman in town.
I need to feel shoulder pain to accentuate the emotional
pain.
How do you say the sweary?
Sweary?
Thank you, sweary.
You like Jasmine, though?
I do.
Yay!
Yes, it is marvelous.
Interesting.
It's from Suihiro.
Ah!
Short for Suihiro.
Oh!
She was really cool at parties.
We lost the most popular person ever.
I have me, Tom.
I feel a bit better today.
I hope you're doing well.
Enjoy the Twin Peaks.
We have a hope.
Thank you, Brandon!
I'm glad you're feeling better, too.
I will preface.
Um...
I was supposed to do some recording today.
After stream last night, my throat was hurting so bad.
My throat is still pretty bad today.
And I have a concert and meet and greet tomorrow.
So for Oshi Uplink.
So today's stream might be a little bit shorter than I
anticipated.
I'm still going to try and go for like two or three hours.
But just a little heads up on that.
Oh, hold on.
Just going to keep looping it.
I made all my streams earlier this week so that I could
stream for longer and then and then but uh yeah um apologies
in advance but for now we play new special what are there
any options I need to What is cruel production?
Oh, change the blood color?
Does it change to white?
Auto save, I cannot turn on.
Okay, interesting.
I will just save often.
I don't trust this game from everything that I've heard
about it.
No, it's green.
Blood to ectoplasm?
Okay.
All right.
New game, baby.
I wouldn't trust AutoZepa.
Ooh, there's some Joker faces in the corner.
It will be peak, right, Zach?
I'll understand everybody's references soon.
Maybe.
Oh.
What body oil does everybody...
Okay.
You've been streaming so much recently.
Apologies are awarded.
Let alone need it.
Take care of yourself.
It takes it a man's...
Thank you!
The eyebrow.
This is the loudest whispering maybe ever to exist.
When AX is displayed on the screen, green, act with A,
observe with X.
Observe.
A strange clock is ticking away, though the room itself
makes you feel as if time has stopped.
Let's do what you can.
You have this more important.
Thank you, Brendan.
A doll shaped like a fat man has a plate on it, which reads,
Washington State.
no wait are we are we back at the pnw oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no i must be why Why is so many spooky
things happening up there?
Oh, so yeah, yesterday was April 30th and today we get the
fat man.
But actually, I know that it's like kind of dreary weather,
but you got vampires there, you got Alan Wakes there, you
got writers there, you got Twin Peaks there.
I blame David Lynch Washington State A dummy for hanging
costumes Gives me the creep somehow Though it might be
useful for jackets and such Or you could just use a hanger
What the heck is this?
Francis York Morgan I'll just add this trading card to my
collection Oh Okay Oh that's me Of course, the Twin
Peaks-inspired game takes place in Washington.
I feel like I need to watch Twin Peaks at this point.
Third-ever Super Chat, Kayo!
Gonna get a happy birthday before we completely get into the
game.
Kayo Moon!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Please call him York, everyone else does.
A white screen.
Oh.
They're getting impatient.
waiting.
It will start soon.
Thank God.
Oh, they shut up.
It's about time to get started.
That's what you just said.
Maybe I will also be inspired by Twin Peaks or something.
I need to go to Washington and I need to do something.
Zach, Zach, Zach, Zach Channel.
Zach, can you hear me?
Someone who has lived in P&W my whole life.
the energy here is just like this i love it you work if you
can hear my voice could you respond is he and gonga oh uh uh
good i thought you went to sleep what zach and gong gaga
don't be surprised the crime took place out in the country
this time let's take it slow okay okay
Tangent, the game goes on.
That's one way of looking at it.
But it's totally wrong.
Francis York Morgan, FBI special agent.
Listen, they both need each other.
It's called interdependency, and they both know it.
My man is on the phone, smoking a cigarette, on his laptop,
and also driving.
He's always asking for it.
Holy hell!
Multitasking!
Oh my god!
Proof?
Well, in the Tom and Jerry show, they live with each other.
We're referencing Tom and Jerry as our proof.
Twin Peaks Watch Along?
Isn't it quite long though?
Francis York Vito.
I can't believe the Bureau still can't get me a satellite
phone.
Oh, no.
I've run out of Wi-Fi.
I can't...
These puppies are making me go to another town in the booth.
I can't use PowerPoint.
I'll be a happy camper.
If it ends up being a waste of time, the very least it can
get me to a cramped city for a while.
Thank you, by the day.
Let me fry some shrimp in the backseat.
What?
Perpetrator from the last case for...
I gotta pay attention, I think.
Who would have thought there'd be razors laced into your
nails?
Just crazy.
At least I now have a scar to show off.
So he's talking not to himself, but to Zack.
Are these police branded cigarettes?
Hide that.
Crazy.
Don't you agree, Zack?
Do I need to agree?
Okay.
You'll absolutely have to watch Twin Peaks.
I would like to.
Oh no.
Oh gosh.
I had a feeling.
I was just about to say I was on the road, buddy.
How actually can he see anything in general?
About the squirrels!
Actually that is not the sound a squirrel makes.
That's not multitasking, that's multitask keg.
Wait!
This is also how Alan Wake starts, please.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you so much.
I'm trying to read them, but I'm also trying to watch the
game.
Thank you.
Is this how Twin Peaks starts, too?
Oh, we finally got it working.
Uh-oh, wait, your car is on fire, maybe?
Cool explosion as he lights up the cigarette and walks away.
no okay wait another
chain smoker there goes the civilized world what does that
mean what what does that mean eyes on the game you shouldn't
be reading this stop yes
what does that mean there goes the civilized world that car
is enormous twin peaks is long but even season one would be
fine fun fact sway sway became a certified buddhist monk
after he took a break from the game development for a time
that's crazy
i will say also just um just a heads up i know people are
gonna are gonna be quite excited about uh the game but try
not to even allude to spoilers or anything let me just
experience as is i don't want to have to like not look at
chat at all um but also there are going to be people who are
uh watching the game for the first time as well so um try to
avoid spoilers for those people as well thank you thank you
let's save oh
Does the flashlight light up the entire world?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
There goes the civilized world.
Oh, what's that?
It's a medal for being a great driver.
David Cage wishes he could be like this.
What the hell?
What is this?
Oh.
Okay.
Rusty steel pipe.
Reach long.
Speed medium.
Strength low.
Oh, strength medium.
durability though what's my toolbox wait can i oh what how
do i use it oh well i guess we have bullets here i'm
assuming the toolbox where i keep my stuff oh okay we have
one pipe take the item out i feel like i should use this i
should keep this on me probably for now
Okay, take the item out, yes.
Five months.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
All right.
Whoa, whoa!
The sky!
Wait, you can't even tell that the sky is fire!
What?
look so adorable.
Okay.
I'm guessing.
Change weapon.
Oh!
Equip weapon and draw it with L.
Draw weapon and aim with R.
Okay.
We have infinity bullets.
Wait, should I move over a little bit?
I like, I don't want to block any subtitles either.
So I'll just, I'll just scooch over a bit.
using.
We have our knife, we have our pipe, we have our gun with an
unlimited bullet.
FBI custom.
I hope Pinto's cafe is a good place to get a slice of cherry
pie and a damn fine cup of coffee.
I don't even know if the kitchen works.
All right, so L.
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Oh my god, it's so slow.
And I can't move.
I can only...
Okay, interesting.
Oh, uh...
I thought this was the way I needed to go.
Maybe I need to beat this up.
I'm so smart.
I understand this game now.
I got five bucks for vandalism?
Ten-say-mento.
are the squirrels back are they devil now I don't know
what's it start profiling no what am I doing profiling what
looks like we're being welcomed what does that mean You
handle the meet and greet.
Extra for profiling.
I...
Which way do I go?
Hmm.
Let's go this way first.
Wasn't there a...
Wait, how do I run again?
Oh.
Hell.
Oh, mysterious.
Can't see much through this fog.
The path might be blocked from the rain.
away from obvious danger.
Obvious danger.
The freaky netting wall.
Does this...
That's fine.
I was gonna say, can I beat that up?
I heard something.
Uh-oh.
I hear something.
It's going...
Wait, is there a dog in here?
My heartbeat.
Something is approaching.
I don't even know what the enemies, what the monsters are
going to look like.
Yeah, it sounds like a dog.
Oh, no!
That blood?
I don't even know what the enemies are going to be like in
this game.
Is this game hard?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, no!
No!
You'll be fine.
Okay.
It's...
Oh gosh.
What was it?
I love his hair, by the way.
It's so great.
It's so...
We have, like, two different meters.
We have, like, our health, but then also our...
I guess a stress meter or something.
So much for my hopes for a peace picnic.
Do me a favor and stay sharp, Zach.
Who the heck is Zach?
What is going on?
The York meter?
I'm staying sharp.
I'm not even gonna run.
I'm gonna take it easy.
These fences, maybe they're for the rocks.
Maybe?
They're quite strange.
Zach I am, sorry, I am Zach.
I am Zach.
I am Zack.
Oh, freaky!
Oh, my stress.
Oh, okay, I see my stamina going up.
Or, like, yeah, I see it going up.
Can I get her from here?
Whoa!
What the?
What just happened?
Can of pickles!
A can of pickles will satisfy a small amount of your hunger.
hungry in this game?
The Pickles.
The Pickles!
Wait, can I take this?
Dang it.
Oh, but a...
Doesn't look like anyone lives here.
Oh, I get observation money!
No reclusive hairy brutes to greet us.
Well, it is like a storage shed, buddy.
There's also some blood right there too.
The pickles.
It's like the orange.
The orange.
Looks like the power grid is controlled from this cabin.
Chances are we'll find a generator or something around here.
Yeah, don't say.
Before we do that though, what are we...
What are we doing this for?
Is there something... Is it this?
Why do I, why am I pulling it?
Oh.
More honor, please.
Whatever that means.
Oh, is it?
Oh, maybe there's something here.
I see it shining.
Aha!
Ah!
Okay.
The door is old, but still functional.
It might move if we had power.
And no, Zach, I'm not resorting to brute force.
Come on, Yor.
Come on.
York!
Picklesack, I could go for some.
I'm famished.
Okay, let's open it then.
Jake, thank you!
Thank you so much for the pick!
Your streams are always infectious with joy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry about your puppy.
I'm so...
I'm glad I can do a little bit to help.
100% York mode, he unlocks a New York accent.
Control panel for the power grid.
This should give us electricity.
Not an expert opinion though.
Oh, it was getting really dramatic there for a second.
It was getting pretty dramatic there.
Green.
Wow, there, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Generator that causes earthquakes.
Where'd she come from?
We're gonna get closer to that.
Oh, freaky.
Pickles.
Oh, maybe I should start.
you got oh i got mysterious shadow equip with l aim with r
yeah draw weapon and lock on with zr wait is my weapon not
drop wait i draw my weapon with l though oh is it like
automatic lock on with zr
oh that was it.
Auto lock is generous.
Yeah, the mysterious shadow didn't do anything.
That was really nice.
Oh, there's more!
Wait, let me try.
Let me... Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
He's coming at me.
I was gonna try the the ZR, but it didn't work.
For a shade kit, I'll take that.
Or I'll observe it.
small amount of health.
Can I take it?
Take it?
Bandage.
Is that loud for you guys?
Let me know.
Oh, shoot.
I did it again.
I wanted to...
Anybody behind us?
No.
Anybody over there?
Alright, I'm walking.
Casually.
Yay!
profiling a pro flat I'm profiling what does this mean
everything
goes so fast I've been through a lot of crazy situations but
that one that one takes the cake it's the first time I've
been attacked so directly Jack can you give me a logical
explanation about what that was never mind don't answer life
is fun because of the mysteries right Zack yep what the hell
I need to know how lollipop sweet sugary candy recovers a
bit of hunger take it take it not ah the chupachup nice
right Zack oh this is how you save I should report to
headquarters get them an update.
I'll try to save very often.
Do you want to save?
Yes.
One save.
Nice.
Chupachups.
Oh no!
No, our power!
Again?
Rout, row.
Oh.
I'm pressing I'm pressing ZR but it's not doing anything So
strange Oh it aims at her butt Why does it do that?
Now why does it do that?
Oh Headshot reward Wait why did it do that?
Center of mass I love that our first instinct was to just
attack these people and like kill them you know like we
don't know why they are possessed or anything or what's
going on we just uh an old sign i can make out grenvale
looks like we're headed down this road zach sounds good
buddy
Anything in here?
Nothing.
Oh, wait, I could push it.
Push?
You could say, I mean, those weekly schedules are deadly
prohibitions.
Looks like I can move this.
It's up to you, that.
What?
Oh, I just destroyed it.
Wait.
Do you think I needed that, or?
I hope not.
Oh!
Oh, I just had a second.
Bullseye!
Yippee!
He gave me another thing.
Another pipe.
I mean, I'll take it.
I'm assuming I have like a max inventory.
Surely.
Okay.
There's a cabin up ahead.
Might as well head there.
Helps to have immediate goals, right, Zach?
I can see a guy down there.
How am I running low on bullets?
Wait, it's...
Are the two...
Wait.
No.
I thought it was infinite bullet.
Wait, it says infinite.
Wait, is the two the number of bullets?
Oh, you have to reload.
It didn't teach me that yet.
Oh, just there.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Got it.
I just have to be careful.
Oh, thank you.
I didn't even see that.
Holy cow, we would have been in trouble.
Oh, this area looks suspicious.
Why is it all bad?
Oh, goopy monster!
Yes, nice shot.
Thank you.
Oh, whoa, oh my goodness.
It's so slow until it's not.
Nice shot.
my god this is not being so dramatic should i should i
actually be like pushed like it says push but for what
reason should i be doing anything with these
no you may be too young for this meantel but direct mention
of zach always reminds me of earnest p world talking to
verne I see I know Oh Nice Wait, do the barrels also?
No, okay Right, Zach?
We usually take a left, no?
Right?
Right, Zach?
Wait, please, okay, there we go Alright Alright This game is
like kind of clunky.
I'm sure...
I'm sure you guys know.
Bullseye.
The game is a little clunky.
Can I grab that?
Okay, thank you.
I love the cha-ching noise.
It's so funny.
Because it's so un-serious For like everything that's
happening Oh dang Everything is clunky Oh geez Alright Like
it moves slow And everything Hello
ma 'am Hmm Hmm
Thank you.
You might say it's part of the charm.
Yeah, sure, I'll believe that.
We need more games that take themselves less serious.
These were masterpieces.
No, I agree.
Less serious is, like, great.
Oh, I get her from behind.
Yes.
Wrong.
What have we got here?
Pickles the Pickles!
Oh, this is my toolbox.
Just kidding.
Do I need that?
Doesn't look like anyone lives here.
Yes, it is.
No hairy broods here.
Why is the music?
Oh, my goodness.
What's going on here?
Why is the music so scary all of a sudden?
Generator looks really bad, Zach.
I think the killer is...
I think the killer really had a grudge against it.
Who's the killer?
What are you being the killer?
Oh,
wait, what's that sound?
She's right behind me, is she?
You got broken.
Oh, machine broken by an axe.
Points to self.
I'm profiling.
What?
It's becoming clearer.
I'm understanding more and more.
let's try to find a way to fix this mess oh oh it would not
be a survival horror game without without a oh my goodness
without a fuse box golly no
generators and fuse boxes we're the one's doing all the
killing lately just i mean we have a grudge against it yeah
what's what's up we're doing the killing though wait oh what
the hell is going on here oh uh well we'll go in here first
oh we can't just kidding i'm a liar
uh locked with a padlock i should be able to break it if i
hit it hard enough oh now you'll use brute force okay
And whack!
Nice.
Very good.
Mushy-mochi.
Oh, it's really foggy in there.
Ah!
Amazing, he says.
Oh, the way they walk is freaky.
What else we got?
Does it look like nobody lives here?
And that no hairy brute is going to greet us?
I feel like I'm being so critical.
Looks like nothing is broken, since it's the same model, I
think I can fix it.
Man, these zombies are flexible.
I'm just curious why there's a generator here and then the
generator over there.
The power in the area should be much more stable now.
Let's hurry ahead, Zach.
I love the sound effects.
They're so funny.
Bad day for the village limbo competition.
Oh.
Everybody's back out again.
Alright, come here.
Oh, that guy is...
Great.
Big, big guy.
Ah!
Yes.
Oh, gosh, I know these guys are gonna get me later on.
You know?
Oops.
Money and honor.
Yippee!
Can anyone give me some answers?
I have many questions.
Ugh.
I forgot I can't move and aim at the same time.
Oops.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Oh, York move.
Oh gosh.
My controller.
Oh my god.
Ooh!
That was a close one.
I could...
Okay.
I'm fine if they're nice and far away, right?
Alright.
There we go.
Why...
Everybody's out today.
He's limbo.
She's limbo.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Are they dead?
Oh, there's a lot over here.
Okay, hold on.
Great.
I like that it does, like, go...
Yeah, thank you.
It like changes for the headshots.
It's kind of nice.
Great.
Thank you.
Who else is...
There's... Oh no, they sunk their car and just straight...
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, oh shoot.
And straight oil.
Oh my god, everybody's crashing their cars tonight.
It's not just us.
Oh my god, he's coming out of the oil.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Oh, the way they move is freaky, though.
Is this game a bit, right, killer?
Did she just say I want to die?
No, don't say that.
I want to die.
Can I die in this?
No.
It seems the car crashed into the electric pole.
Suffering power.
Quite the nuisance, huh, Zach?
Where'd the driver go anyway?
Why'd he just leave this car?
I don't know, maybe because there's zombies everywhere?
Or something?
Where the hell did you come from?
Oh my god.
Holy cow!
Where'd that person come from?
This game is a sanity killer.
You never quite look at the world the same again.
Oh no, they keep spawning.
Okay, let's keep going then.
I'm just gonna run past them.
Ah!
What if I don't care?
Eh, they don't follow.
Dang it!
I will reload though, just in case.
Stay and fight them!
Ow!
Quick time!
Uh oh, am I about to die?
What did it want me to do?
Wait!
Wait, what did it want me to do?
I did it!
I did this!
Where is it?
Where is it gonna put me back at?
I wonder.
Oh!
Oh, okay, I'm here.
I thought it put me way further back than I thought.
Oh, shoot.
He's gonna get me.
He's not gonna get me.
I'm gonna get him first oh i think he said i don't want to
die i don't want to die
oh yeah oh my goodness okay okay amazing it's okay thank you
I don't want to die.
Amazing.
Yes.
Get him in the booty.
Uh...
I've...
No shot.
But they're gonna just keep spawning there.
I don't want to die.
Oops.
Bullseye.
He's so proud of himself, yeah.
Nasty.
I shot.
Yes.
Great.
Thank you.
I don't think there's anything over there.
I mean, eventually they'll stop, right?
Maybe?
Oh, there's a second one.
The one that spooked me before.
I don't want to go.
See what's down this road.
I don't think that... It won't let me go past the red stuff.
Oh, shoot.
I need to run, please.
Thank you for holding for me.
Oops.
Why did I shoot?
A shot.
Let's see if anybody else comes out.
Oh, see?
Yeah, they just...
I think it's endless.
Alright.
Oh, my gosh.
Leave me alone.
Amazing.
They shine.
No, they just keep spawning.
So we're gonna run past.
And it's...
Wee.
I'll kill this lady, maybe.
Oh gosh, if I could see her.
The auto is kind of nice, actually.
The auto aim.
Okay.
Wee.
I was
wiggling.
I don't want to die.
All right, buddy.
Oh, I'll keep forgetting that I need to reload here before I
go after him.
Yes.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, now I'm screaming it.
At least I know that I don't need to just sit here and like,
what's it called?
What is that like sound, like stretchy sound?
Amazing.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I didn't have him, like, come after me now for...
And...
Right.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, shoot.
I'm so dead.
Heh.
I don't want to die.
Amaze, amaze, amaze.
Ignore, ignore, ignore.
Ignore, ignore, ignore, ignore.
Ignore, ignore.
I'll get her.
Ah, geez.
What does it go?
What if it's X or Y this time?
Ah, okay.
Lock in.
Alright.
We're locked in gamers.
Wait.
I'm just gonna keep running.
Guys?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, finally.
Ah!
I pressed B!
Oh, wiggle.
Okay.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Oh, I evaded!
No, no, no.
Oh, we're not going to comment on that at all.
That's fine.
I get it.
No, eh, eh.
Wait, let me at least check what the door says.
Oh, I think...
Oh, I thought it was...
Oh, just kidding.
Observe.
Red ivy climbing.
I didn't realize it was red ivy.
I thought it was like the stuff that...
blocks the way.
If we don't go through it soon, the red ivy will lock it up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Don't want to die.
Oh, that's the sound.
That's supposed to be, like, ivy?
Is this a boss battle?
No way.
Oh, I got red.
I got the third picket.
the third clue we can now we can now do everything we can oh
my gosh we can now profile profiling burger Dalmatian oh
there's still one thing oh there's a couple things missing
lollipop how am I supposed to heal the game did not teach
sugar donut
least something in this town no kidding do you feel it zach
my coffee warned me that i your coffee yesterday morning the
milk i poured in my coffee meet assigned it said tomorrow
you'll arrive in a place that will change you said all that
that's like my coffee coffee cup
Let's save, holy cow.
Let's save the game.
What the?
Why is the road so wet?
Oh, it's my shoes probably, no?
I like the thing he's calling his detective buddies Jenkins,
Halligan, and Nancy Trudeau's soft stories.
The sign reads, welcome to Greenvale.
So we're finally here, Zach.
Yeah, I put this person in like the Guinness Book of World
Records.
Oh, there's a second sign that says, welcome to Greenville.
Okay.
Don't talk to me until I've had my coffee and it talks back.
Wait, another one?
Why are there so many signs welcoming you to Greenville?
I don't quite understand what the clock is and the limit and
stuff.
is it's so quiet okay oh yeah this is good old washington
state
you'll see okay oh first aid kit who are you police oh now
you were very late Emily Wyatt, Greenville Deputy Sheriff.
All these games are so similar.
I didn't think you'd keep me waiting in the rain for so
long.
You watch Twin Peaks, you'll understand.
FBI special agent, Francis York Morgan.
Please, just call me York.
York.
That's what everyone calls me.
Solidus, happy birthday!
Good, that's good.
Good.
Are you the sheriff?
No, I'm Deputy Sheriff Emily Wyatt.
he's the sheriff he went looking for you actually he should
be back soon i see if you don't mind me asking did you walk
all the way here my car broke down that's all
my car broke down stairs is it is this love at first sight
what's happening she's easy on the eyes definitely worth a
trip to the primitive world where she get she's right there
don't think you're a psycho don't want that do me Zach don't
tell her about what happened in the woods okay um hopefully
she can't hear me I'm the sheriff George Woodman George
Woodman I have a question did you walk all the way here
where's your car FBI special agent Francis York Morgan but
call him York just call me York that's what everyone calls
okay oh could you tell me why the FBI is so interested in a
small town homicide let's just say it's a personal interest
in killers of young women I'm always looking for new sample
cases to help me with my profile the profile both our
superiors have cleared this with each other you can remain
in command you don't have a problem with this do you no no
problem Shifty eyes Just want to set things straight Our
small town has its share of problems I'm the one fixing them
one by one And maintaining peace and order You can have your
profiling sample But I need you to understand that Yes Of
course Lots of peace going on here By the way, George, I had
a little accident with my car Could you send someone to take
care of it?
oh and my clothes and luggage are still inside oh they're
probably exploded by now I'll get my assistant Thomas to
take care of it she's so pretty you need anything else
thanks that'll be all well then I think I'll rest up first
at the hotel you'd run a hundred yards to the cutscene
letting you gasping and exhausted for like 16 minutes don't
know how to say that but uh really don't need your help.
Unlike some of your corrupt city police officers, I play it
by the book.
I hope you'll come to appreciate that, Agent Morgan.
I said...
And we'll handle the investigation.
I said, call me New York.
You just think of this as a vacation.
Take it easy.
Enjoy the nature here.
You don't have to be a tree worshiper to appreciate the
wildlife here.
But everyone calls me.
Let's reassess the situation.
There are no cavemen.
in here.
We're as far forward as the Middle Ages.
And we've just met the king.
What is this problem?
He's literally calling everybody NPCs.
He's like, I'm the intelligent alien life from the future.
And these are the cavemen and the...
Oh my god.
Number of days.
Yay!
200 bucks!
Basic wage, unpaid salary.
Is that how much I collected on the road?
Badoom.
The Joker faces are so funny.
Of course I want to see Zachville.
These are making me go to another town in the boondocks
again.
I didn't think you'd keep me waiting in the rain for so
long.
Welcome to Greenland.
Call me George.
I can't hear you, Woodman.
Do you feel it, Zack?
I coughed at one.
I keep having to turn the volume up and down, like,
constantly.
So sorry if it's a little, if it's a little, uh, uneven.
Oh, where'd the twins go?
What's here?
Oh, a sugar donut.
Oh!
Yeah,
the audio mix is quite janky, huh?
That's okay.
Oh no!
When is...
When...
What happened?
One's backwards.
Looks like the door wasn't locked, I guess.
Our TV!
No!
Angel Isaac.
I'll just add this trading card to my collection.
Okay.
Number 14.
Wait, there's two doors.
Yeah, this is our mind palace.
It's locked.
Okay, that one's locked.
Locked.
Poor audio mixing just adds to the game's charm.
Oh, okay.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Does add to the game's charm.
Oh, what's happening here?
He's not walking that fast.
Is that me, baby?
Is that me as a baby?
Sick pajamas, kid.
No!
Don't breathe.
Hold your breath.
you if you hold your breath.
Hurry.
Like this.
Cover your mouth.
You don't have to cover your mouth, though.
Oh, ZR.
What if I let go?
I'm so tempted.
Eww.
Keep walking!
Oh.
Let go?
Oh, this is Tomodachi life!
Okay, that was fun.
If you let go, Tomodachi life updates.
What did it update?
Yeah, I'm playing on the switch.
Good night, Brendan!
York!
Why are they communicating in a way that I'll never
understand?
Sure!
Don't breathe.
Hold your breath.
They can't see you if you hold your breath.
I'm going to try holding my breath.
Are we going to do anything?
Maybe keep going?
Sorry, I couldn't even keep...
I couldn't even...
It's so dramatic.
Oh.
But he's still right there, no?
Vivikor, thank you so much for the fuck it did!
I'm you.
This is the slowest fate.
Oh.
His eyes were open.
Is it too bright for you, little princess?
My eyes!
Oh, he's got the California king.
Damn.
This room.
This is what the Airbnb is mean when they say this place
sleeps four.
Wait a minute.
Who are you?
You could lay a horizontal vertical.
The symbolism in my dreams continues to intensify.
A forest of red trees.
Chain smoker, you lork.
A carpet with red leaves.
A strange doll.
And twin angels.
Wait, I didn't see the doll.
But that child is what bothers me the most.
Did I?
I swear I've seen him before.
I just can't remember where.
Is it me or is it Zach?
Cigarettes for breakfast.
Well, it'll probably come back to me eventually.
Just imagine if this game was...
He needs coffee!
He needs a coffee to talk to him.
If this game were made...
Nowadays, he'd be vaping.
I'll pay him some real coffee.
I really need some coffee.
Okay.
Then we can head to the sheriff's office.
Alright.
It's got my...
There's a proper procedure for everything, right, Zach?
First.
Oh, wait.
We could actually sleep?
Looks comfortable enough, though.
I'm starting to miss my own bed back home.
The coffee.
I
want the banana Oh do banana portrait What
My toolbox Oh Oh There's actual working mirror Wait oh Wow
this place is nice We can make berries Oh, my favorite
recipe.
The door wasn't locked.
Oh,
wait, this is...
What are we...
What is this bathroom?
Can I flush?
No.
Okay.
It's so quiet.
What's in here?
Oh, you have a bath and a shower.
Okay.
Not bad.
What would you say if you had to guess what this game's
pause menu looks like?
Black screen with just white text?
What the hell?
Item?
Oh my god.
What is a key flag?
Okay, that makes sense.
Mysterious shadow.
My god.
Trading cards!
Killers MO.
The red S.
Sood?
The red sood murders.
Official trading cards.
Why does a murderer have official trading cards?
Oh, seed.
Oh, that makes sense.
That makes sense.
Some of the cards have spoilers.
Okay, I wasn't going to look at them, so thank you.
But just to make...
Yeah.
Profiling options.
Wow.
The deer is blinking.
Oh, the deer is moving.
Oh, the deer is so cute.
Oh.
The deer is so cute.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Oh, and there's like cookies.
Oh, what is this?
What is this place?
They have the little figures.
I wanted to see the pictures on the wall, but...
Let's shave.
Is this a minigame?
Dang, I was hoping so.
It's so quiet.
I literally just only...
I got money for shaving.
I just hear the hum of the lights.
Simple guide to Greenville.
With an overview of the shops in town.
A&G diner.
Delicious turkey sandwiches.
Milk barn.
Convenience store with rock and roll.
music if you don't sleep the deer will start going crazy oh
enjoy your evenings at galaxy of terror why why would i do
that and uh sway sway sway you know sweat i don't even know
how to sweat i'll just call sway sweary 65 too many drinks
drop by the green veil general hospital
goofy ass game can we go out here I have a feeling I forgot
something, Zach.
What's that?
What do we forget?
Swearie, okay.
Oh, my coffee, of course, my bad.
Great angle.
I love being able to see nothing when I leave my room.
Please, oh, I thought I said wake up.
I'm really enjoying the artwork in this game.
Hello?
Check the weather?
Today is a fine, clear day.
A perfect day to have a walk.
Oh, my eyes.
I got money for checking the weather.
Nothing here of any interest to me.
What's this?
Open it?
Yeah.
Oh.
What is it?
Oh, what's it?
It's just an egg.
Okay.
I got egg.
Awesome.
This game rocks.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
Does anyone care that I went behind the reception and...
Various expensive sounding dishes are listed in the menu,
though none of them really appeal to me.
I'll opt for junk food and coffee anytime, right, Zach?
Is this a coffee?
Oh, yeah, baby.
This is not the coffee we want, though, I think, probably.
Yeah, it's still telling us to go somewhere else.
Uh, this place is ginormous.
We can just go anywhere.
Did you find the pickles yet?
I did, yes.
I could shave again.
Please.
Not bad.
Urinals.
That coffee doesn't talk.
Yeah, you're so right.
I can just go anywhere.
I can go anywhere.
Anywhere.
What's this?
Various records of the history of the lumber mill.
They have a timeline of events, but frankly, I'd rather read
something I'm interested in.
Closed.
No wonder.
Holy cow.
This place is huge.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't want to get lost, so we'll just go to where we need
to go, I suppose.
what's this oh I can save here sure I'll just I'll just save
any time that I can it costs a buck I can't give
headquarters an update but it'll cost me one dollar Zach
rooms along the corridor yeah it's a payphone it's actually
a payphone with the paintings and along the corridor with
the exhibits on deer.
Polly lives in the suite, a dining room in the center with a
view of the lake.
We can also go out onto the patio.
There's a boat house by the lake, so it's a floor plan of
the hotel.
Looks like you can fish in the lake.
I don't think anything he just said makes any sense.
I don't think anything he said makes any sense.
Food stuffs.
kinds of food stuffs.
There's so much almost Resident Evil in this.
None of my favorites, though.
Picky.
Picky York.
He likes to point at himself.
Good morning, Mr. Morgan.
Your breakfast is ready for you.
Grandpa!
Thank you, Mrs. Polly Oxford.
Just Polly is fine.
Well then.
Thank you, Polly.
I'm starving.
Is everything all right, Mr. Morgan?
Yes.
Yes, it's delicious, Polly.
My compliments to the chef.
I'm hoping my cooking will bring back repeat gifts.
Honestly, though, it's been a while since anyone has stayed
here.
Oh my gosh.
What was she doing?
She's- Aside from you and me, there seems to be no other
guests or workers around.
What's that?
I can't hear you over the music.
Salt in that white shaker there.
Thank you.
I was wondering if there were any other guests or workers
here.
Oh, no, no one else.
My husband and I used to run this place, but he's in heaven
now.
You've been working here alone since then.
yourself oh my what i'm very sorry it must be difficult to
run a hotel by yourself well yes i suppose i could just live
on my pension this place is to admit running a hotel is kind
of like a hobby a hobby this location poly it might help to
hear you better if you could sit a little closer oh my mr
morgan you're embarrassing me so early in the day too i
think i'm a little too old for you and i still love my
departed husband may god rest his soul i appreciate the
invitation but i'm fine over here holly i can hardly hear
you from all the someone turned down this music this is fine
it will do to be all clumped together with such a large
table and it's getting louder now tell me that wound on your
face what happened let's just say i had some trouble during
the last case i was working on i'm sure it'll heal it's just
a flesh oh my well there's no need to be the top guy here
it's just a flesh i want you to be able to relax here i've
prepared a special room for you a famous rock star once
stayed in the same room you know really oh wow i feel
honored is that the same one that we're in anything at all
just let me know i'll help you out in any way I can.
Zach, the lady is offering to help.
Do you want to ask her about the town?
Uh, uh, yeah, yeah.
Say, Polly, what can you tell me about this town?
Well, let me see.
We might know this already, but the town is called...
Why is the music so loud?
It rings here quite often, but it's a nice place, surrounded
with nature.
It was a big and a long-standing lover town until not so
long ago.
We used to have a population of over 6,000 people.
Is he paying attention?
This hotel was built back then.
We saw plenty of guests from those days.
What is that, Polly?
That's why this place is so big for such a small community.
I have seen...
Oh my god!
I suppose the clock on the community center is quite famous
too.
Clock?
Oh yes, it's locked.
I'll move over so you guys can see the subtitles.
It's...
I can't hear it.
You'll hear it many times during your stay.
I don't think I'll hear anything ever again, Polly, after
this.
I look forward to hearing it then.
Anything else you'd like to know about?
Uh, tell me about the shops here.
Yes, actually, Polly.
Could you tell me about the shops around here?
Shops?
Well, there aren't many.
It is a small town, after all.
You can do most of your shopping at the Milk Barn
convenience store.
Why is it called the Milk Barn?
They are a unique pair.
I'm sure you'll get to like them.
The A&G Diner is a great place to be.
I'm watching a studio shaft to animate with A&G.
They might be open even if my kitchen is closed.
If you want to go to a bar, there are two.
The Galaxy of Terror and the Sweary 65.
Sweary 65.
I don't care much for either of them.
What?
Why?
Who made that coffee then?
Wait, she's the only one working here.
She does everything?
You should be able to find what you need.
Thank you, Polly.
Well, Mr. Morgan, I better start cleaning up.
You just take it easy.
I'll bring your coffee out in a moment.
I took her coffee!
I have to warn you though.
It's very particular about my coffee.
The very best you have, please.
I understand.
I'll be right back.
George says that his own hearing is decimated by this
museum.
This is Kaz's voice actor.
I have no idea.
What will it say to us?
York, if you really were a coffee man, you wouldn't put that
much creamer in it.
Just saying.
Oh, I'm looking with interest.
Did you see that, Zach?
What?
Clear as a crisp spring morning.
F.K.
In the coffee.
I knew I could count on it.
Never fails.
let's get going
what is this okay we're fine maybe i mean this place is in
like crazy impeccable shape for being owned and taken care
of by one woman holy the best smile i need to know Where
does York get his lip filler done?
Forgot something.
Okay, we're just gonna keep going.
Voiced semen in that old dream casket.
I don't know which one you're talking about, actually.
Have some fantastic coffee and find out what your fortune is
for today.
Can I do it again?
He's not going to survive this game.
Terminal levels of goofy will be her doom.
It's too good.
the unexpected trouble is coming your way lucky item lighter
there's always trouble heading my way in this job but I'm
always up for a little excitement too same again oh where
where would more more more oval teen please you will have a
lot of fun today lucky place theme park there's no theme
park in this town though oh well that good luck is just
slipping away no but i think i'll have a thrilling enough
time right here anyway okay get me out of here get me out of
here these like not these like strange quick time events or
anything else in here meals are served buffet style nothing
noteworthy on the menus with the hotel being this big i'm
not worried about the quality of the food but i'd opt for
junk food any day this guy's right deck why is a raven like
a writing desk wait why is it buffet style this is all for
me i think i'm the only one here no
york is so funny
like there's like that stereotype for survival horror games
but like when when the protagonist is like a female you know
the female survival horror game protagonist why can't we
have a cute girl that acts like this best part of waking up
is clairvoyance in your cup female the female What do you
mean by this?
Wait, you've never seen that?
Where it's like, there'll be like videos that are like, I'm
a girl in a survival horror game.
You've never seen that?
We love cute girls who are a little stupid.
Oh, hi.
Oh, if you need anything, you can find me at the front desk.
I sell daily goods to guests.
I don't have much, but they may help you out.
So you're the sales girl too, aren't you?
Yes, that's right.
Coffee comes as a set with the breakfast.
No worry, the service here is just as good as any fancy city
hotel.
Great, thank you.
Alright then, did you want something?
No, I think we're fine.
Her hearing is quite weak, but otherwise she's fit.
Fit enough to run the hotel by herself.
Let's go.
Oh!
Wait, what?
What was that?
Okay.
Yes.
Wait, did the level hotel?
Good job, leave.
Worm!
Wait, we can go fishing!
That is not a turkey sandwich, I think.
A police car.
Our office is open.
Oh, don't be late.
Fit, she's standing at a 90-degree nightclub.
Preparing a car for me.
A pleasant surprise, hey, Zach.
Oh, he gave us a...
Let's take it for a spin.
Why does he talk like he has a codec?
I have to tell you, Zach, this place simply amazes me.
The keys were left on the front hood, and nobody stole the
car.
There's nobody here.
Values.
What is Polly going to take it?
This town has what the country needs.
Values.
Let's head over to the sheriff's department.
Oh, geez.
No, what?
The wipers?
Oh, wipers, no.
A steer?
Honk.
Oh, my God.
signals.
Oh my God.
Talk, change view, accelerate, break, reverse, boost, side
break.
What the hell does that mean?
Headlight, I'm not going to remember any of this.
Hold on, I'm screenshotting it.
I'm not going to remember any of this.
And save source screenshot.
And I'm just going to hold I'm just going to have a nice,
tasty little cheat sheet up in the corner.
Okay.
There we go.
All right, let's go.
Uh, sure.
Okay.
I got the master key.
And a flare.
Swery legitimately went and put in every little detail in
this game, including physics for the bed sheets.
It's why.
Where's the...
I think I'm going the right way.
Did they drive on the left side of the road in the PNW?
Oops.
What?
There's something I needed to see?
Oh, there's other cars.
Maybe that's what was supposed to be so scary.
Sorry!
Don't mind me!
Please.
merging the talk button about those bonus features in dvds
nowadays what you know the ones from the 80s have almost no
bonus material even if they do it's a trailer and the visual
quality is pretty bad well that visual quality is a good
reminder of those days so many new audio and visual
appliances were coming out back then do you remember the
first video deck we bought we bought it to record one of the
star wars movies on tv and remember when that video store
opened we spent hours there just trying to find a good movie
to rent there weren't that many to choose from back then i
remember renting some really bad ones after reading those
back cover taglines hey guys riding his brakes come on man
tomatoes filmed in 1978 produced directed written and edited
by john de bella for some reason i still remember it pretty
well we had so many sequels and the original was re-released
in 95.
am i going the right way 87 minute long theatrical Wait, I
think I messed up.
I think I need to go this way.
I got lost in sauce.
Once this case is over, we can launch it together.
I bet we can buy a copy of it.
No.
What's the speed limit here anyway?
Come on, Grandpa!
It's gotta be higher than 30.
Oh, I think I need to turn here.
We're doing good.
Small town driving.
I'm flooring it.
I'm boosting.
Oh!
They're going to get out of my way.
Jesus!
No,
that's not a road.
My bad.
Uh...
We're fine.
What's the wipers again?
Oh, here we go.
Okay, we're close.
It reminds me...
Oh.
Oh, I thought this was it.
Just kidding.
Sorry, everybody behind me.
Uh.
There's nobody behind me.
I drive a car.
That's why I'm using my blinkers.
Duh.
Turn off?
Where is this place?
Oh, we're here.
Oh, we'll take another lap so we can listen to the
conversation.
Deadly spawn.
You remember that one, Zach?
Back in 83.
We'll take the scenic route.
What's this?
Still pretty cheap, but still, it was pretty good.
The monster design with the mouth crammed full of teeth.
I loved it.
So many delicious B-movie cliches.
made a sequel but I never got to see the sequel the rental
store didn't have it for some reason they said the staff for
the sequel was totally different from the original I turn
off wait I have gas oh no you know the monster in that one
responded to sound oh there's multiple oh wait there's a
there's a trading card up here I think that one was back in
89 directed by Ron Underwood now that was a great role for
Kevin Bacon.
Kevin Bacon!
But that's a real person!
It's like crazy.
There was a fourth one.
I've only seen the first one.
Yeah, he's talking about tremors!
Wait, that's a real movie!
Let's get our trading card.
Zach, is there something here that you want to check out?
We're supposed to go through Anna Graham's file at the
sheriff's office, but if you want to act on a hunch, then
I'm with you.
Lily Ingram.
Huh.
It is once again silent.
Can we take this car?
If I ever feel like taking another car?
You ever play a game and the dev just starts talking to you?
This game is a wackadoodle.
Wait, which one's mine?
Which one's my car?
Is this my car?
Yeah.
When did I park?
Dang, I'm so good.
I didn't even realize I parked.
I thought I just stopped in the middle of the road.
Game is peak.
Twin peaks even.
Ah, right back at you, buddy.
Police business here.
I don't think Zach can hear you.
Do you think the music in this game is diagetic or not?
Nobody can hear anything ever.
Mmm, country ham.
Oh,
it's the guy that was crying.
Absolutely diegetic.
Otacon?
Oh, oh.
Girl, girly.
Pleasure to meet you, Agent Morgan.
Girly pop.
Oh my god.
Thomas McLean.
FBI Special Agent Francis York Morgan Please just call me
York That's what everyone else calls me Very well then,
Agent York I believe I owe you a thank you for retrieving my
belongings from my car Oh yes, thank you No, no, just doing
my job I just...
I just can't believe Anna was murdered No, Anna She was such
a bright and lovely girl Did you know her well?
Well, no, not really over her what do you mean don't know
her that well it's just that this is the first really big
case I've ever seen I understand just try to relax can I
have a look at Anna's file now yes of course the sheriff
told me to let you through to the meeting room but I've lost
the key to the cabinet where the files are why don't you
take a look around while I go look for it okay let me know
when things are ready
Zach Thomas appears to be the kind and sensitive type
totally at odds with the monarch almost a good I think it's
shadows on his face but it looked like a giant vein was like
pulsating throughout his face
abducted wait there's some stories here
let's save brother's body language I love it he's the kind
and sensitive time office room conference room real people
more everybody's Emily I was gonna say everybody's looking
sideways, but suddenly Emily.
Hello.
This person probably has nothing to do with the
investigation.
Can I talk to him?
Oh, no.
What's crazy?
Oh my gosh, I'm getting a sense of deja vu for this game.
Door isn't locked.
Oh, the locker room.
What do you mean the door to the locker room isn't locked?
locker room.
It's in the...
Looks like Emily's locker.
I'm curious as to what's inside, though we shouldn't be
snooping around.
Come on.
Come on, you...
Oh, iron body!
George's locker.
Looks like it's seen a quite a lot of use.
Spartan, just like the owner.
What?
Long-tailed flying squirrel keys.
Key holder?
With a long-tailed flying squirrel attached to it.
The key belongs to the sheriff.
I'll take that.
That's a sugar glider, no?
It's hardly a mystery who uses these, is it, Zach?
The locker room is the one who locks.
What's in here?
Can we change outfits?
Oh my gosh, suit crimson!
Suit with a red jacket.
Sometimes it's good to change image.
Looks almost brand new.
No problem.
Suit made for an elite FBI agent.
Perfect for work in the field.
Workaholic.
Businessman suit.
Perfect for long hours of overtime.
I like the red one.
What does cleaning mean?
my toolbox.
Wait, did I just spend that money?
No.
That's how much money I have.
Oh, thank goodness.
You get stinky after a while.
What?
What is this game?
Kitchen room.
There's so much to explore.
I can shave in the kitchen.
Why is there a dumb in here.
Use for working out the muscles.
It says Arnold on it.
I wonder if that's an Emily.
I wonder if that's Emily.
I wonder if that's the name of the owner.
Zach there's a name written on this dumbbell.
Arnold.
I haven't met anyone by that name yet.
Could it be the owner of this dumbbell?
What do you think Zach?
We're just gonna stick this in our pocket.
Have a happy birthday!
Ronaldo, Joe!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Don't be nervous!
Thank you for the super chat!
Happy birthday!
Observe.
Small kitchen of sorts.
Turning out tasty dishes from here.
Now that's a true talent.
It says Thomas on it.
What's this?
More squirr- why are we getting- oh, this is a grace- what?
Why does everybody have them?
What is it?
A tur-
Oh, I'll just add this trading card to my collection.
Wait, no, but it says turkey sandwich.
Oh, it's a card turkey sandwich!
What the hell?
That does not, that's quite honestly not a turkey sandwich.
Where is Emily?
We have the material room, the storage.
Dang, this place is huge.
I'm never going to finish this game if I'm always looking
around at stuff.
Storage is kind of bleak.
What's that?
What's this?
More pointy tails flying squirrel!
Why am I getting so many of these keys?
A raincoat?
It doesn't look like it's been used much.
Even though it rains here pretty often.
What waste of nice fabric, Azak?
Hmm.
Well, organized storage room.
No doubt.
This is Thomas's work, too.
Whoever gets to marry him will be spoiled rotten.
Could be you.
Could be you, detective.
I've seen what's important enough.
Was it the same coat that the killer was wearing?
This person has nothing to do with the investigation.
Oh, wow.
What's down?
Thomas.
What is down here?
Is this where they hold people?
Oh!
The killer had a red one.
It is where they hold people!
Hello?
Oh!
Looks like the door isn't locked.
This place is actually ginormous.
Whoa!
Shooting range!
more that looks like a chipmunk
york and thomas would be hella cute and zach
this actually it's kind of giving me there was this one like
so i've been watching like this video of this guy like
explain not explaining but just going through every episode
of black mirror and there's this one episode where this lady
gets into a car accident and she's in a coma for years and
then this guy comes and is just like actually I can transfer
her consciousness into your brain and and so they do that
but then she's with him all the time and then he's just like
well you know she can like feel when when he hugs their kid
and things like that and but he'll be like he'll be like
doing something and she's like hey um you you're not doing
that correctly and he can like never turn it off she's just
always watching him and then he like falls for another lady
and she like starts freaking out it's
so quiet it's so quiet until it's not don't be afraid to get
sidetracked and look at all the weird stuff there's a lot of
fun in this game yeah oh come on i hear that let's go let's
see who's in the cells Chip monkey in Japanese is Shimari
Shu.
Literally striped squirrel.
Whoa!
Whoa, most wanted.
Who are you?
Nothing to do?
A desk for the warden.
Is it even in use?
Doesn't seem like it.
I could s- I could sleep in here.
I think I'm not tired, probably.
I can definitely get some sleep here, Zack.
I don't think we should.
Do we need to?
Is anybody else in here?
Oh!
Hopefully we'll be bringing in the culprit soon.
Though that'll mean the end of our little vacation here.
Sorry.
Oh.
I'm getting cat.
Who left their money in the jail cell?
Curvy tail.
Why are there so...
so many keys.
I guess it's good that I'm looking for them now, or finding
them now, I suppose.
We'll need them at some point, surely.
I can sleep in that bed.
Can't sleep in this.
Oh, wait, I can open this one.
Chail break!
Oh, no.
Actually, it's agent honor, not money.
sorry I don't know what he did he could be the world's worst
murderer ever just let him free all right let's go to where
we need to go finally in here I've seen that episode of
black mirror he pulled her out of his mind put her in a
teddy bear yeah yeah yeah yeah that only had two dialogue
options yeah yeah yeah yeah I like that episode because it's
like kind of I remember Like, a couple stories in one.
It's interesting.
Time it.
He's like, does he see me?
Let me like, let me just act on that and chill on it.
Is it?
Is it looking this way?
Oh my God, he's looking this way.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just, I'll just continue looking at this shelf.
Just all like, oh, oh, he's, he's got, oh, he's walking this
way.
Oh my gosh.
Act natural.
What are these anyway?
Oh, they're all like tapes and stuff.
Okay.
Hi, Thomas.
Agent York, did you find the key?
Oh!
I have pickles.
Wait, where are the keys?
Oh, here they are.
How do I know which one it is?
I'll give the first one.
You found the key?
I think so.
Is this it?
Does this mean anything to you?
Huh you don't know your squirrels do you this isn't the
right keyholder?
This is a Siberian flying squirrel.
It's closer to a land-based squirrel The Siberian flying
squirrel is larger than the southern flying squirrel and has
a standing tail while the southern has a hanging tail But
we're looking sorry.
I know so many things about the squirrels What are we
looking for?
Oh, no a lot of about squirrels what is going on in here
anyway automatically sliding storage quite modern for a
small town archives room beep whoa there's
nothing in them is there a point to Oh, oops, beep.
That's so cool, though.
Oh, there's stuff in here.
Oh.
Okay.
Maybe I should observe it once it's open.
Uh.
If it'll let me?
Never mind.
Okay.
I don't even know which one I'm trying to find again.
Should I find the key?
this one you found the key I hope this is the right one
we're holding up each and every single little squirrel
squirrel you found a Siberian chipmunk this time have you
sorry wrong key a Siberian chipmunk nooks and jerks happy
birthday this season we live in northern Japan on the island
of Hokkaido they're actually quite a popular pet oh so it
isn't even a squirrel that's what I said for a southern
flying squirrel southern flying squirrel oh but I want to
hear more about them
long tail gray curvy master key we'll do the gray one this
is like your typical found the key typical guy no is this
the one you were looking for
no this is a gray squirrel sorry that's not the key nothing
particularly special about the gray squirrel I'm afraid you
can find them in the US Canada and in England too yeah I
love those guys a gray squirrel what was I thinking but
we're looking for a southern flying squirrel right now
nothing interesting about them actually I have so many
pictures on my phone of
hold on I took some recently oh my gosh wait I don't think I
can show you guys it might give too much information oh oh
wait maybe I can show this one I have like 10 pictures in a
row I love them I love those guys They're so funny Let's see
Oh I'm scared We'll do the car retail You found the key
That's the right one Car retail Please say no No Yes A
southern flyer No!
I'll bring the files right in, so please go to the meeting
room.
Okay, he's smiling.
Oh!
Is that Emily?
You've cracked a big case already.
She's just standing there.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
She was waiting for us, maybe.
The victim's name was Anna Graham.
Age 18, she just recently graduated from high school this
year.
Oh my gosh, she was so young!
was to move out to the city and become a model but for the
time being she was working in the A&G diner here in town she
lived with her mother Sally on his father died in an
accident in a lumber mill when she was a child Anna Graham
and lives on the insurance money from her husband's accident
wait she had a small town with a low cost wait she lives on
the money of her husband's accent if i find and they led
normal oh the their mom is exactly what a curious teenager
doesn't want it's all starting to make sense sack the music
is giving like incredibles it's so funny
ew city folk huh no no i take that back all of them can't be
as bad as him some should have better manners for real this
is a good biscuit i've I've never tasted a biscuit this
delicious.
Where in town can I get these?
Well, actually...
Thomas, house husband, for real.
I baked them myself.
That's amazing.
What are you doing in law enforcement?
I'm very particular about biscuits.
This is the balance of milk and butter you've achieved here.
Oh my.
Agent Morgan, the autopsy's ready.
Somebody has died, York.
Come on.
Greenvale General Hospital.
Emily, you come too.
Thomas, stay here and tidy up these files.
Yes, sir.
We're going to use the car outside.
Let's get going.
He's like saying all this, surrounded by photos of missing
children and evidence of the crime.
Mmm, biscuit.
I kind of want a biscuit now, too.
Oh, yay!
Yay!
Oh, what a game.
This game is awesome.
To be fair, it was a really good biscuit.
I want a really good biscuit now.
What places have good biscuits?
Woo!
The Greenvale General Hospital is down the road by the lake.
It's too far to walk.
Come on, get in the car.
If I'm riding in a car, George, I prefer to be the driver.
Uh-oh.
Can you provide a car for me?
What are you talking about?
You don't even know how to get there.
Which is another good reason for me to drive, George.
What?
Oh, I guess that's fair, but...
Oh, man.
Then I'll ride with you.
I want to keep an eye on you.
Why is he so suspicious of me?
Just one thing, Agent Morgan.
Your involvement in this case is limited.
That means you don't have to learn your way around town.
George, we better get moving.
Because you're a weirdo.
Okay, that's so true.
That's very true.
Wait, she said they close?
Oh, we could get food.
Head towards the hospital.
as quickly as possible.
So that's a clock.
We need to get to the hospital and get those autopsy
results.
We have 11 hours to get to the hospital, yeah.
I get my car of choice.
Oh, I want the beetle.
Oh.
What just happened?
Agent Morgan, don't tell me you intend to walk there.
I won't be joining you if that's the case you mind if we go
separately oh uh let's let's stay together i did have
something i wanted to do but i'll do it later that's the
case get in the car davy thank you i get the intent is to
characterize york as a multifaceted character having
interest slash quirks you'd never expect but it's done so
clumsily that it's just hilarious It's a fiction.
He's like, he's like really crazy Columbo.
Like, Columbo is like, you know, let's get going.
He, he's such like a bumbling, like, he's, he's the
unassuming type.
Like, you don't, you don't think he's such a genius.
And, cause he's just like a bumbling little guy with his,
with his big tailcoat and everything.
But York is like, God, but York is just insane.
Oh, he's...
Morgan, get us there quickly.
But drive within the speed limit.
Just because you have a badge doesn't mean you can drive
like a maniac.
I would never.
What are you, his mother?
Oh, my God.
The weather here is crazy.
Agent York isn't accustomed to the town yet.
Isn't that a little slack?
He's like smirkist.
I would never drive like a maniac in this small town.
Let's get going.
Sure.
good yeah yeah oh my wipers uh how do I oh sorry no one
behind me let's go wait how do I get out of here
uh uh uh that way it's so loud oh I'm talking I can't help
notice Hold on, hold on Don't you get alone?
Is there any way to The sound balancing?
Please God Options
Okay, here we go
That should be better That should be better No!
Here I'm I'll go to 70.
Oh, uh, wait.
Yes.
It's already perfectly balanced.
I'll go crazy.
Wait, uh...
Uh, do you wish to have the new settings reflected now?
Yes.
Oh, uh, my bad.
Uh, where am I going?
My very realistic...
Driving simulator?
Oh, my goodness.
Frame right in.
Oh.
Oops.
Okay, this way.
They're telling me the most effective, efficient way to get
to the hospital.
This way.
The weather is...
I thought the weather said it was going to be a perfectly
sunny day.
I got some honor.
Going through the secret road.
I can't see it.
Oh!
What is this?
A bone?
Why is there a bone here?
Stay in the car?
I'll handle this.
If you're wandering off, then we'll go on ahead.
No, no, no, no.
We don't have time to mess around.
No, no, no.
Okay.
I'll meet up with you later.
Agent York, the hospital closes at 2100.
Oh, okay.
Please make it inside the fire.
Oh.
They couldn't handle me.
Is it your...
Oh, how do I put the gun?
away put the gun away put the gun away you you monster and i
pet the dog okay the game might be bad left hand bone from a
human the frame rate is dying you guys a human bone this
doesn't look related to the case but shouldn't i let someone
know Okay.
This is fine.
Three FPS item viewing.
What happened?
Can you pet the dog?
I don't think so.
No, it won't let me.
We can't pet the dog.
Wait, I wanted to talk more to the people.
Uh, my wipers.
Very important, actually.
Don't worry, the dog is safe, I think.
We're close to the hospital.
See, I took the special shortcut.
Uh, uh, uh, nobody's that way.
Okay, we can go.
I'm talking.
Trimmers.
Oh my god, he's talking about tremors.
We can fish here.
That's right.
Remo Williams, the adventure begins.
That one was back in 85, I think.
Directed by Guy Hamilton.
Wait, is this where we fish?
We're aiming to start a series like 007.
I didn't have no sequels.
Real shame.
Do you remember the martial arts they used in that film?
Called Sananju?
The ultimate in martial arts.
Using no weapons at all.
Remo's master chug ran across water.
He ran across water.
Water!
Man, that's a good character.
He was played by Joel Gray, the best supporting actor in
Cavalry.
Ugh, the lightning flash is too much.
Sinanju.
Oh, wow, the brakes are really strong on this car.
There we go.
What's it say?
Parking lot!
Oh, to the, okay.
To the right.
everybody.
Big tree!
Anything in here?
Just a few cars.
This is the most empty parking lot I might have ever seen
ever.
Like for a hospital.
In my whole afterlife.
Alright.
Yeah!
We made it safely!
Greenvale General Hospital.
I like our little raincoat.
Our FBI coat.
What?
You're waiting for them.
And now you try to go in by yourself.
Oh, George.
I didn't see you in the parking lot, so I thought I'd wait
in since I knew.
I'm just watching from now on.
I'm sorry.
They're mad at me!
Forgetting the human bone!
I don't like it.
Consider it.
Oh, sir, it is like pouring down rain.
I don't think...
She probably just got lost on his way here and rushed in.
I'm sorry!
She's not... Can we get out of the storm, please?
Wait, we could eat a whole bass?
This game is...
Oh, the dirt outfits hello sheriff oh freckly Fiona you
couldn't give her a real name hi there Fiona we're here to
see Usha you know where he is I think dr. Johnson is in the
computer room the computer room in a hospital nice to meet
you mr.
FBI agent the computer room is where our employees share a
computer very nice to meet you too I'm FBI special agent
Francis York Morgan Oh, that lady in the background scared
me.
I would never know that somebody died based on this
soundtrack.
Even in the countryside.
What's that you're reading, if I may ask?
Liar's house.
You haven't heard of this yet?
It's a recent bestseller mystery.
It's set in the US.
traditional north american town close to the canadian border
a peaceful traditional place like this place that peaceful
town is shattered by a terrible crime like this place causes
grief and sadness to everyone in town now written by alan
wake his evil still lurking alive yes much like the
situation right now here in greenville fiona don't say that
sorry i shouldn't have said that with anna dead and all
don't worry Books are written to entertain.
It's good you're enjoying it.
What we're faced with here is a terrible crime committed in
a real world.
Much different from that of a novel.
Is it?
She described the situation to a T.
She described it completely.
I've heard this whistling music used so many times.
Never knew where it was from.
Now you know.
Dr. Johnson should be in the computer room.
I love the computer room.
Emily, how you doing?
Why?
What's going on?
Oh.
I was just asking.
Who are you?
No relation to the K-side figure.
What's she reading?
Something.
Looks like some novel.
No smoking in here!
Oh, York is gonna disintegrate.
In two seconds.
Who are you?
No relation to the case.
You never know.
Playboy magazine.
Do not enter...
The flattest do not enter signs ever.
All of these.
Ward.
Oh, we could just go into the operation room?
This is a really dark space.
spooky hospital.
Wait.
What did he say?
No relation to the...
Did he say they're not...
Oh, they aren't suspects.
Let's go, Zach.
Save your life.
Like your life, wah-haha.
Registrationing and fill room 8.
Therapeutic...
See what?
Blood.
Rhine.
Dollar sign.
collection x-ray room hello kitty chest x-ray fa-fa my girl
polyclinic medicines exam of internal medicine for men and
woman premarital exam what what does that mean for male
surgical exam for girl premarital exam for female gynecola
gynecola I kind of call a logical exam for child premarital
educationer.
I can't speak.
What does that have to do about saving my life?
I'm very curious about the...
About the Fafa My Girl?
Fafa My Girl!
Treatment room.
We'd be treated here if anything happened to us.
Let's go in.
What's happening in here?
Hello.
Are you being treated?
Zach, we have little use for a TV right now.
Our favorite cartoon isn't running.
Zach, turn off the console right now.
Why would it even be on?
If our favorite cartoon is not even playing at the moment.
We could sleep in here even!
Oh, our toolbox.
Wow, our stuff is literally just anywhere, isn't it?
This is insane.
This is actually insane.
No time in Jerry.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Oh my goodness.
What's in here?
Oh.
We really can just go anywhere.
This place is so...
We have the Medica Mint storage.
The Hickey storage.
Dissecting room.
Dead house.
Sleep lab.
Toilet and power room are that way.
Love your eyes.
Roadrunner cartoons.
I can't believe this isn't a PS2 era game.
Like your eyes.
Waha ha ha.
do i love them or like them i'm getting mixed messages here
caution your body i'm just going through hallway after after
hallway even for a town of 6 000 people what there's now
what 600 people even for a town of 6 000 people this place
is too large it's too big the difference is colombo is
putting on an act to low the criminal into a false sense of
security york is just york oh yeah no i get that i get that
why is the women's restroom literally chained yeah go in
oh my god well
people not like me if i am not shaved not bad
be a trading card in one of these don't go in and shut the
door god damn it we don't need to do all of that come on
yeah you clean that what i mean clearly right next to the
urinal
somebody went a little if you run you can go through the
doors faster oh really that's like huge Wow!
Oh, awesome!
We're just busting down walls now.
What is this?
Turn...
It's locked.
It might open if we find a card key.
Locked.
Oh, I'm gonna have to come back here and remember how I did
it.
If I run more, I wonder if my stamina gets better.
Oh, great camera angles we got here.
Alright, I've done...
Wait, there was this hallway here.
I was going to say I've done enough exploring, but I want to
explore just a little bit more.
Never mind.
Uh.
Run!
It's so...
Quiet.
It's so quiet.
What do you got, George?
Let's go to the computer room.
We need to find...
Usha?
Usaha?
I'm like that.
They put a thing on the doors that you can't open because
they're like, well, we know you'll try.
We know you'll try.
this looks like somebody receiving bad news
this looks like a room the room is in use we shouldn't
interrupt the process oh now he has manners okay can we use
this no let's check the other direction
yes all right just leads us back to here.
All right.
Anything down here?
Oh.
Do not enter.
This door leads to the wards.
We have a little reason to go there, and it's unlikely that
they have that many patients.
If that's the wards, the... What is here?
What is this?
What have we been passing through?
Why has it changed?
We couldn't find him.
One minute here, happy birthday!
Yona needs to check her information.
Good luck on your card tournament!
Good luck!
You got this!
Oh my gosh, chess tournament on the game too.
And a card key already set in place.
The king passes the rook and meets the bishop.
The knight takes a pawn along for the queen.
all mean it's a simple puzzle no let's take him up on his
challenge you can do this right no no don't
don't imagine being told bad news of some random guys
running around the halls dramatically busting through doors
all around you wait the king wait i don't know which is the
bishop and which this this is the king this is the queen uh
what is this one is this the bishop bishop is second to last
okay this is a rook and this is a knight
right okay so the king passes the rook So maybe the rook is
first and the king passes him to meet the bishop.
Bishop.
Wait.
Passes.
King passes rook and meets the bishop.
The knight takes the pawn to the queen.
I've lost!
What do you mean that?
There's a lose?
Zach, something is still missing.
The voice actor for Agent York is apparently...
The guy in...
Wait, the guy...
The voice of the briefing officer in Ace Combat 4.
No.
No, he's not.
That would...
No.
Chest pawns displayed on...
I think it's a riddle.
Wait.
Can I try it again?
Maybe the king is first since it's past the rook.
Well, that's what I did.
Rook?
I did rook king.
Oh, God, he is!
That's insane!
I think it's just the order they appear in the hint.
Rook.
Bishop.
Knight.
Pawn.
How is... what?
Okay.
Oh, Jesus Lord.
The doctor awaits below with the deceased.
Another code?
But there's nowhere to insert a password.
War games.
I'm going to get Fiona to call Usha up here right now.
Usha, Usha, Usha.
The message appeared with the card key.
It's telling us where to use it.
Oh, I finally...
This is not the time to be joking around, Agent Morgan.
Dr. Usha is below with the deceased.
With Anna.
Below being underground, I take it.
Simple.
Usha, Usha, Usha.
Then it's time to meet the mischievous architect of this
little game.
Why is the doctor...
Why can you only meet the doctor if you solve a riddle?
Sir, I'm bleeding out!
answer these me riddle three if you wish to have the key
like what are we doing for real riddle me patient how long
does it take for somebody to bleed out nice weather in the
morning but cloudy in the afternoon at least it's It's not
raining.
That is a blatant lie!
This is, that's the most realistic part of the skin now,
isn't it?
This guy looks pretty pale.
Is it that different than your midnight doctor summoning
ritual?
Don't bring that up, please.
I'm trying to forget.
It's down here?
Why did you guys notice that the hallway is like crooked?
I'm not for honor, but for you.
I remembered how to get there.
Turn on.
Load Barry Callaway.
I was worried that this game was gonna be...
Similar to Alan Wake and that it was just gonna be combat
after combat after combat until you're exhausted of it.
So I'm glad that it's not quite that at the moment.
You know?
Uh, phone.
Is this a payphone?
It'll cost me a dollar!
Even if it becomes that later on, at least right now it's
like more, you know, everything else.
What do we have in here anyway?
A lollipop and a single cracker.
I'm sorry, is the cracker $35?
And a lollipop is $24?
You'll get an appointment.
Wait, wait.
You'll get an appointment when you answer me this.
What does the airspeed velocity of an unladen swallow?
No.
You have to answer something about you have to tell me a
really cool fact about the gray squail and they'll be like
How much money do I even have oh, oh wow
We're rich
That's a set of numbers I haven't thought of in a long long
time Not sure if I should be more afraid of the inflation or
the fact that a saltine costs more than a lollipop I'm
concerned about the whole thing.
I'm concerned about everything.
Oh, it says suspects.
Should do these riddles for her beat grease.
Dr. Usha, what is your favorite color?
Usha, sorry to keep you waiting.
Usha, you made it.
Let's get started, shall we?
Usha Johnson.
This is a Agent Morgan who thought the music was like
appropriate nice to meet you I'm Usha Johnson the doctor in
this hospital FBI special agent Francis York Morgan please
call me York everyone calls him that very well agent York
everyone by a certain George let's just say I've dealt with
corpses before I'm sorry is Anna right there by the way did
you create that yourself mm-hmm i just wanted to see if our
fbi agent could handle the task i see she really is just
right there glad you liked it we're cracking jokes in front
of the deceased we don't have much time we need those
autopsy results everyone's like acting shocked but he's the
only reasonable person i think try challenging us without
obstructing an investigation i think george is the the
monarch i love how tone deaf this game is it's like george
is trying to solve a crime from the onset of rigor mortis
the stiffening of the muscles the time of death between 20
and 2200 hours that's still quite early for such a crime to
take place note that there are two exterior wounds pressure
marks around the neck and a long cut running from chest to
Yeah, it's freaky blood marks on her right hand tell us she
was gripping something round in her right hand
Everybody looks at their hands.
What could I be gripping in my hand?
The skull is also fractured, but that is unrelated to the
cause of death It probably happened to her after she was
killed.
Oh my god
Egg now I first thought death by something vacation due to
the marks on her neck but after further investigation I now
have a different conclusion what's that doctor give it to me
straight the direct cause of death was loss of blood from
the wound oh that's the worst so the one in on her abdomen
she was alive for that which means she was cut up while she
was still alive oh holy feet a sharp knife huge it was
inserted beneath the sternum and then quickly sliced down
the excessive loss of blood from her internal organs is what
actually killed her her nails are clean and with no skin
cells from the attacker she also doesn't appear to have been
bound nor badly beaten she was apparently killed without
resistance oh it's a cult the most tragic thing however was
that she was unable to speak her story to anyone who could
hear her cries what does that mean now sacrifice the
perpetrator cut out his
drugged first to phase her consciousness and then the killer
killed her back to funky town the killer most likely has a
deep traumatized past concerning women he probably cannot
converse with them normally cutting out the tongue we could
have we could have kept the other bgm it's still either that
it's still it's still fitting to the conversation he must
get off on watching women suffer especially when they can't
answer back now he watched as the blood pumped from her body
as she gradually grew cold a case in Seattle in 1985 was
much like Usha please limit your report to your findings as
a doctor criminal profiling is my job oh okay you can't just
let the guys speak you're wrong also Anna died fully,
deeply, painfully aware of what was happening to her.
But, uh...
What, how do you...
Tell me, what time did it stop raining on the night Anna was
killed?
Uh, just before I went to bed, right after the movie on TV
ended, so...
Around 1 a.m.
What movie was it?
Oh, he's the guy loves movies.
The American werewolf in London.
Oh, I like that movie!
Directed by John Landis, 1981.
so the rain that one has great special effects practical
effects George would you mind if I examined Anna myself what
more do you hope to find I'm sure I mentioned that I have a
personal interest in cases like these that's strange to say
oh I'm looking and I'm observing his age isn't immediately
apparent though he can't be that old.
Looks like a trustworthy doctor.
My man is pondering.
We shouldn't stare at her for too long.
What happens if we do?
I'm looking.
I'm looking at her.
Yeah, you said the old noggin.
She gets shy.
Does she turn red?
Oh, sorry.
He's still...
He was like, I have to look busy.
Still no hint of a smile.
There's no reason we should focus our efforts on George.
Oh, gosh.
Traces of evaporated liquid around the eyes.
She must have cried before she was murdered.
Those are some...
Narly tears.
Her hands.
She's neatly wearing fake fingernails.
There's a symbol!
Judging from the impressions, she was holding something in
her hands.
Oh, that's what they meant.
But it was removed around six hours after death.
The object was circular with a relief shaped like a piece
mark.
Piece to piece.
Metal gear.
Anna's body is lying on the table.
Those?
Those are so...
something no comment on the feet um was she like mid
werewolf transformation what is whoa whoa
those are crazy not sure the tongue has been removed look at
the edge of the stump
when it's launched a patrol car will come oh nice of
resistance, I'd say that Anna's injuries happened very
quickly.
Unable to speak, she was then left to cry herself to death.
Aww.
Maybe it is mascara.
It's all starting to come together.
The perpetrator stayed with her for at least two hours until
it stopped raining.
At the estimated time of her death, it was still raining.
But you can still see tear marks on her cheeks.
That means she was killed under a roof somewhere why is this
the rain how does he know the rain she was then carried into
the woods after it stopped raining hmm there is one other
thing her tongue was removed with a very blunt knife in fact
it's more likely it was simply chopped off Asha are you a
passionate man well not particularly I man enough should the
moment call for George how about you I'm very passionate yes
especially when it comes to his eyes are crazy but I don't
see what that has to do with anything George the perpetrator
is just like you he's passionate about women he's a
passionate kisser this was a kiss of death Ah, the
perpetrator bit off Anna's tongue.
You bit it off!
We'll never get a dental print from a wound like this.
But this is still a big lead.
I want to see the tongue.
Ugh, ew.
What the heck is...
Shame, but our old-time all-American sightseeing tour just
came to an end.
This case is now under the jurisdiction of the FBI.
I'm assuming command.
I'll need you to assist me in the investigation.
What in the hell do you mean, Agent Morgan?
It's like the calling card of the...
I know I said I was passionate, but you can't think...
Now the red suit!
That's not why I'm assuming command, George.
You're a suspect just as much as every other passionate man
on Earth.
Let me show you something.
Oh my god!
Why does he keep them in bags of three?
There you go.
Amazing, huh?
I'm sure you have a lot of questions, but most of the
details are top secret.
He likes three.
George, Emily, we should be going.
No need to stay here any longer.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I have to sign the release.
Just give me a moment.
He pulled them out so dramatically.
Even the first bag was enough.
But holy cow.
I think they need to hire a new person for this case.
Bishop takes queen.
His rook takes your queen.
If he was able to kill this many people.
And checkmate.
Huh?
Oh,
he's too cool.
Oh, he's...
He solved his game for- My first victory in the Grandmaster
ranking.
Does this mean anything to you?
Proceeds to dramatically reveal bag collection.
What the hell?
We're back in our- wait, we're in our mine palace, but it's
the hospital.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we're not in our mine palace.
We're in the- we gotta start shooting things, palace.
Zack, they're here.
So it's...
Paranormal and not.
Why was the doctor playing chess in the operating room?
Or the autopsy room?
Yeah, great question.
Uh, do I go through here?
Okay.
I hear something beyond there.
I hear something at all.
Actually, I'm...
Was I... Oh, okay.
I can open this door.
I think it's like a silent hill situation.
Oh.
Can we play chess?
No?
Okay.
Oh!
What's that?
was that her you
what's the breathing oh no they're gonna come out of the
inky blogs or blots sorry not blogs sorry the blots the inky
inky bits shelves restoring bodies I wouldn't open these
unless we really need to well maybe we do
clearly something's making that sound
10 millimeter wait I'm so confused about how my so I do have
limited ammo I just is it so it's just the durability that
is infinity oh it's for another oh this is 9 millimeter I'm
so silly you're right you're so right oh There she goes.
There she goes.
There she goes again.
Oh, nurse.
Running through the heart.
This one walks backwards.
You don't want to die.
I don't...
Oh.
I don't want to dodge!
Kill!
Kill...
Oh.
Wow, that was clean.
Are these gonna come out like...
I want to die.
Are these gonna come out unlimited too?
Oh.
Okay, I thought I was hearing something else.
This one's kind of stupid.
Why is the music atmosphere so...
I need to stop asking why the music is blank.
You know?
I think I can stop asking why something is strange in this
game.
You know?
Amazing.
Great.
I got the other one, but it still works.
Don't want to die.
Oh!
I guess we'll be getting another gun soon then, I imagine.
There's so many hallways, I'm trying to be a little...
Oh!
A little, uh...
Careful about...
Bullseye.
About running through them because it's such a tight area.
The uneven...
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Haha!
Oh...
Okay, that answers which way we go.
Oh, this is the way it was locked before.
I'm hearing something.
Like a lady crying.
It's very quiet.
We're laughing?
One or the other?
Where?
Oh, she's scared.
Oh, you again.
He's such a good hype man for himself.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
He's just like, yeah, I'm doing well.
I'm doing good and I know it.
Okay, it's definitely Lady Crying.
Yes.
They're operating on someone?
Is this a boss?
The Sims!
They're woo-hooing.
What's this?
Is that a coffee?
I'll take it.
Coffee black.
This feels like a boss room.
It's covered with a white cloth.
What should we do, Zach?
What is it?
Oh.
Hard key for central building.
Thank you.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
I'm leaving?
Please leave!
So scary!
It
doesn't seem like they respawn, which is nice.
But your honor.
I think I'm good.
I think.
I think I'm okay.
Oh, there's some down there.
I had to bust down all these...
We could do it.
Don't want to die.
Yeah!
Heya!
Nice honor.
30 honor.
Back to good.
Uh...
Reload.
Okay.
Can you just shoot the boxes?
I don't know.
Maybe?
Probably?
Probably, kid.
This seems like our door!
No, we have the key!
It's locked!
No, we have the key, no!
Is this it?
Oh, wait.
Maybe I use it right here.
Oh, I'm silly.
Seems like a waste of infinite ammo.
Infinite ammo.
Hello.
Through here.
Is this like using tank controls or something?
That gameplay looks like OG RE4.
Hold.
Okay.
We're about to go to a boss fight for real now, aren't we?
Yes.
Thank you.
I can't believe I have to pay to use this phone.
Oh!
Stabilizer.
Look at the clock.
I like how all of the curtains for the, uh...
Wait, actually, can we nap?
Yon, I'm sleepy.
Oh, a light sleep?
I don't know.
Oh, I'm hungry, though.
So how do I eat?
Item.
Side main item.
It won't let me.
Do I have to in my toolbox?
Maybe I have to at the... That's not my toolbox.
There it is.
Oh, I have to press A?
Oh, my bad.
Oh, okay, okay.
Small amount of hunger?
It's pickle time.
I'm just gonna eat a raw egg.
I...
Huh.
Let's take this.
Stabilizer.
Makes my mental okay, I guess.
What is this?
Mission knife.
Whoa.
First in kit medium?
I'm scared.
They're giving me a lot of stuff.
Lollipop.
Okay.
I'll waste.
another dollar.
Boss fountain.
The boss fountain.
What does that mean?
Oh, like, oh, like a bunch of stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was wanting to call it soon.
So I'm like, hmm, wait.
Oh, I can take more lollipop?
Yeah.
I guess.
Is it?
Is the boss difficult?
Oh, no boss?
There's not actually a boss.
You're kidding me.
Oh, wait.
Hold on, I'm going to save again.
Wait, if I save, then another lollipop appears?
No boss, just enemies.
I don't remember a boss.
Oh, my God, it really does.
That's funny.
Thank you.
Gameplay makes every boss hard in this game.
Okay, that's fair.
This is...
Wait, where did we come from?
Uh, which way do I go?
I guess I'll go this way.
Oh, dang!
Sounds pretty close.
He's right there.
Yeah.
Oh, there's one there too.
Oh, let's get this guy.
Get this guy over here.
The big guy.
Yeah.
Should we drop something?
It'll look like an egg.
Okay.
Oh, no way!
Another guy came through!
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, they do disappear though when you get through enough of
the guys.
Don't want to die.
Wait, that sounded bad, whatever that was.
Oh, there's like a little trail.
I'm gonna try shooting these.
Oh, it takes so many bullets.
So many.
Don't want to die.
To do...
Dickie...
Hmm,
curious.
Here, over here!
Kind of realistic, I guess they would just mostly punch
through.
That's true.
Here!
Over here!
I had a feeling that was gonna be the case.
Where is my...
Here, I'll just...
Oh, there it is.
Great.
Yes.
We're sniping them.
Over here.
Over here, silly goose.
That just looks like a regular lady.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Don't want to die.
What is that?
Regular boxes?
Oh, I'm not even shooting it.
Oh,
physics.
Ah!
Sorry.
Scared the heck out of me.
Ah!
I should clean up my inventory.
Wait, toolbox.
Uh, so we need a key for...
Wait, does our key still work?
Or...
It's locked.
Okay.
Wait, what's this say?
Nothing.
Never mind.
Oh, the room that we couldn't go in before.
MRI.
Okay.
Anybody in here?
Take that.
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
Phone booth.
Awesome.
this one I shouldn't have to pay for it's just a regular
phone hello headquarters I am stuck in Silent Hill um just
updating you on my current situation thank you uh what's
this take our med kit yeah it's getting real spruppy okay
I don't know what we're doing but We're doing something.
We're tickling the keyboard.
Oh!
Oh, that's probably our...
card key!
Nice.
Yeah, nice dodge angle.
Key to entrance.
That sounds good.
That sounds like we can get out.
Okay.
Alright, how many people have respawned?
Uh, maybe it's fine.
Alright.
Fun.
Uh, yeah.
Good, good.
Alright.
Get me out of here.
Well, why does it sound so wet?
Oh, it's still raining outside.
Oh, wait, but my honor!
No!
Oh, okay, they just keep coming.
Found you.
Did you just say found you?
Woo!
Okay.
We're surrounded.
Another one.
one three of them mmm the
money tempting me let's run over here and let's grab this
guy first I think he's dead oh no he's not oh shoot oh shoot
we're so dead amazing oh What the hell was that?
Oh my god, is he tasing me?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, uh...
There we go.
What the hell?
Where's the other guy?
I think he's still over there.
Now we're getting...
Where... What am I getting another gun?
I'm getting...
Shell... I'm getting all these bullets.
I'm going to reload.
load before we really go for this guy.
Alright.
But he doesn't even notice that I'm here.
It's kind of awesome.
Yes.
Bullseye.
Is this it?
No.
The wrong kind of headshot.
Uh.
Okay.
Oh.
What- what did that- Thomas's biscuit!
It recovers life, hunger, and tiredness and prevents them
from lowering.
Thomas's biscuit is so powerful.
Oh, we did it!
Agent Morgan, if you're so desperate, then why not smoke two
at once?
In the hospital?
Come on, man.
This is what happens.
We start hallucinating when we don't smoke.
What?
No.
Who is...
Who the hell is this?
Who's that old man?
That's Harry.
Harry's just Harry.
Just Harry.
One of the bigger problems around here.
His father started up the lumber trade and founded this
town.
Helen Wake.
They're connected.
I know it.
Sure you can see.
Always dressed like that.
Never speaking to the town's folk.
And just FYI, he owns almost the entire town.
What?
Even me.
So long as I'm around, he won't be getting away with any
funny business.
Hello, Harry.
Normal man.
Mysterious capitalist.
Mr. Francis Yorkmore.
you to what you seek.
Keep your eyes focused on your footing as we speak.
He speaks in riddles.
So says, Mr. Stewart.
Michael Tillotson, Harry's aide.
Nice to meet you too.
How did you know my name?
What the hell is happening?
Mr. Francis York Morgan, information desires you just as you
desire information too so says mr.
Stewart so says mr.
Stewart Harry stop trying to get my controller keep this up
and even you'll have to answer to the law
mr.
Francis York Morgan with each rain our town goes mad to our
disdain unpreventable so sad so says mr.
Stewart thanks for the warning yeah ignored then we shall
depart Mr. Francis York Morgan.
I like how he says his whole full name.
And all is now happening.
That's how he always is.
Always spouting that nonsense.
Don't give it any thought.
It's all gibberish.
Emily here.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Okay, thank you, Thomas.
Agent York, we've contacted the first witnesses to the crime
scene.
You can interview them where they found the dead body.
Excellent.
I was just about to ask if you could take me there.
Yay!
Oh, wow!
Oh, nice!
You're safe, please.
And this is where we will call it, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Um...
Chocolate chip cookie...
Root beer...
Hold on, hold on.
Oh my god, this...
The license plate is spy fiction.
She's hard to walk.
A forest park.
It's the pride of the town.
It has a beautiful trail leading to a viewing site over
Velvet Falls.
That does sound fantastic.
Show me the sites.
Um, that may have to wait.
We promised to be there by 1800 to interview the first
witnesses to the crime scene.
Okay.
Yay!
Wait, well, let me save.
Hold on.
I do not see a place.
Oh, wait.
Phone.
Oh, over there.
I just want to manually save, you know?
I know I just did, but I want to manually save as well.
well yay okay this was oh wow wow spy fiction was sweary's
previous metal gear knockoff game shut up dargo thank you
for the peek guys don't say goodbye don't want to say
goodbye we're so glad we're taking time you're taking time
to rose thank you for the stream this game is such a riot
the sound design is something hope you have a great thing
good luck tomorrow thank you thank you if i see you guys at
oshi uplink then i will see you and if not um i'll stream
sunday so yes yes yes this was so fun i hope you guys are
enjoying uh deadly premonition as much as i am because um i
don't quite understand it but i think i'm enjoying it
actually no i know i'm enjoying it i don't understand it i
was looking forward to you playing this and your reaction so
far i've not been have not disappointed best of luck with
the concert tomorrow i'll be there in spirit thank you thank
you thank you so yes um but yeah i had so much fun i hope
you guys did too we will continue this next week and um yeah
yeah salty zero thank you for now i'm gonna go because my
throat be hurting.
My throat be hurting, but it is a good time.
It is a good time.
This game is so funny.
Why is it so...
Wait, the clock isn't...
The clock is going.
Okay, I should probably pause.
Well, I saved the game.
It's probably fine.
It's fine.
But yeah, thank you so much, everybody.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
And I will see you when I see you to minto what to minto
what to minto bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye